[Musique]
donc là on voit un petit peu la séquence
par rapport à quelqu'un qui vient de se
brûler avec une brûlure thermique chaude
la Rose a essayé de faire des crêpes
elle s'est fait mal donc première chose
qu'il faut faire effectivement on assure
la protection et puis on voit la brûlure
là en fonction de la couleur de la
localisation
détendue effectivement ça sera grave ou
pas là effectivement c'est grave parce
que c'est un peu foncé
c'est en même temps il y a des cloques
c'est étendu donc on va commencer tout
de suite par l'arroser doucement avec de
l'eau tiède tempérée d'accord donc 15-25
degrés d'accord on va arroser à brûlure
un petit peu au dessus si elle supporte
pas on se met au dessus pour que ça
ruisselle et que ça ne lui fasse pas mal
pendant qu'elle est arrosée je vais
téléphoner au secours pour expliquer la
situation dire qu'il y a une personne
qui s'est brûlée et que la brûlure était
tendue elle est un peu noirâtre il y a
des cloques elle est supérieure la
moitié de la paume de la main et pour
connaître un la durée d'arrosage et leur
demander de venir une fois que j'ai
atteint la durée d'arrosage préconisée
par les secours
et bien effectivement je vais allonger
la victime au sol pour préserver la
conscience et puis pour préserver la
chaleur de son corps puisque en fait
chez les brûlés le danger si
l'hypothermie et l'infection et bien
effectivement je vais couvrir la victime
et effectivement attendre d'arriver des
secours si maintenant la brûlure est
simple et bien on va pouvoir rester 10
20 minutes sous l'eau pour pouvoir
atténuer la douleur de la victime sans
être obligé d'appeler les secours